Salve mi chiamo. Karim e questo è il mio mondo
Il mio lavoro principalmente consiste nel vestirmi in modo ridicolo per il vostro giubilo personale ma soprattutto creare intrattenimento
partendo quasi da zero in qualunque forma e con qualunque mezzo.
Ma ogni tanto la vita mi dà una mano, regalandomi emozioni che soltanto una mente umana potrebbe mai concepire
La storia che voglio raccontarvi oggi ha tutti gli elementi per essere un nuovo canto di natale
Un nuovo punto di riferimento da raccontare ai nostri nipoti
Questa è la maxi storia di come la mia vita è cambiata,
capovolta sottosopra sia finita.. per colpa di un'applicazione
Il 2016 è stato l'anno di pokemon Go. Ve lo ricordate, no?
Quel gioco che c'ha sparaflashati talmente tanto che è riuscito a portare
alla distruzione la vita di alcune persone.
C'è addirittura un sito che tiene conto di tutti i morti e i feriti causati da quest'app
Pokémon GO Death Tracker.com
*canta male we wish you a merry christmas*
Tenendo conto che Pokémon GO è basato sulla tecnologia di Ingress
È diventato talmente popolare che ha fatto trasformare le pupille di alcune persone in piccolissimi simboli di dollaro
dando vita ad un incantevole copia-incolla
Jurassic World Alive ti permette di catturare i dinosauri
Ghostbuster World ti permette di catturare i fantasmi
Garfield Go ti permette di catturare
i Garfield (?)
Tirando pezzi di lasagna nella loro ciotola
nel 2018 la gente pensava di guidare auto volanti. Ma ci siamo vicini
molto
vicini
Si stanno avvicinando le festività natalizie, ma voi non avete ancora idea di cosa regalare alle persone a voi care
vi presento...
Follow Jesus Christ GO
Ne avrete sicuramente sentito parlare perché ha creato parecchio scalpore
Il gioco che ti permette di catturare i santi: le battute si sono sprecate, le critiche ancor di più
perchè con delle premesse del genere sarebbe molto facile cadere nell'insulto
alla fede o alla religione di una persona. Io al contrario sono curioso di sapere cosa ne pensino proprio le persone di fede
di una cosa del genere! Perché tutti, quando sono uscite le notizie, hanno gridato allo scandalo ma veramente veramente pochi
l'hanno provata. D'altro canto dare aria alla bocca è molto più facile che alzare il culo è vero?
Quindi...
...l'ho provata io per voi
Nonostante il gioco asserisca essere in inglese in realtà è completamente in spagnolo. Cerco di districarmi tra i menu e riesco a
Trovare "nuova partita". Mi chiede di compilare un micro questionario sulla mia diocesi e la mia parrocchia e quindi faccio
Quello che avrebbe fatto chiunque... vado nel panico. Ma fortunatamente si può bypassare tutto quanto. In Follow
Jesus Christ Go puoi scegliere il tuo avatar e adesso vi faccio ridere
questo è il secondo avatar disponibile
Scelgo questo (lol)
Come funziona il tutto è molto semplice: camminando per strada trovi varie icone. Quelle"di cattura" sono
"Invocazioni alla madonna"
"Santi e martiri"
e "personaggi biblici"
e quindi vi chiederete: come si...
... "CATTURANO"...
... I Santi?
Rispondendo vero o falso ad una loro domanda
Semplice, diretto...
... In spagnolo (XD)
Se la risposta è quella corretta entreranno a far parte della vostra squadra. Io sono riuscito a trovare
Jesús Eemilio Jaramillo. Quello che più mi ha intrigato però sono le tre barre
Di fame, sete e fede che tu devi riempire trovando delle monete di pane
Vino e fede per strada e questo trasforma Follow Jesus Christ Go...
...
... in un survival!? (vabbe però)
C*zzo la religione può essere brutale a volte
Invece, in caso di risposta errata,
Il gioco mi chiederà di riprovare al costo di tre monete che si possono trovare sia in giro sia
acquistare con soldi veri...
... tramite micro transazioni...
... che in gioco chiama...
*Karim pondera perchè stia facendo un video riguardo il gioco*
*Adesso cerca di capire con che coraggio affrontare quello che sta per dire*
... Donazioni
*Il cringe si fa sentire a questo punto*
Ouch!
Comunque, tralasciando la questione di nero, trovo che l'app sia
...
Estremamente innocua
Che non sia questa tragedia che tutti si aspettavano che fosse quando sono usciti tutti questi
articoloni e titoloni da prima pagina
Anzi, vi dirò di più: per una fetta di pubblico probabilmente molto molto giovane potrebbe anche esserci
del...
Vago intrattenimento dentro
Pure le recensioni sono positive!
Certo, sono state scritte da
...
"Jesuslover6000"
*povero Karim*
e "horney😈4jezus"
Con... con una faccina del... del demonio?
Quindi non credo siano proprio attendibilissime...? (ma vah?)
Ma io sono agnostico, non posso capire quanto questa cosa possa effettivamente...
PESARE su una persona di fede
Quindi mi rivolgo a voi: una cosa del genere è forse troppo?
E ricordiamoci che è stata approvata da Papa Francesco in persona!
Lui e il social media manager di Dio!
🤣
Quindi è come se l'avesse approvata Dio!
La considerate comunque blasfemia?
Ormai un pizzico di blasfemia si trova ovunque
Uno per esempio per festeggiare il natale, no?
...
... LA NASCITA DI GESU'...
non va in un negozio a comprare un bell'addobbo...
... e... e... e...
... e ritorna a casa con
"Gigetto Il Babbo Che Muove il Culetto"?
Io personalmente non credo che Gesù avrebbe mai approvato
Una cosa del genere dopo tutto quello che ha passato poverino...
Dovrebbero fare dei piccoli adesivi con scritto:
"Approvato da Ponzio Pilato"
E appiccicarlo su queste... tipo di... di addobbi secondo me
QUESTO puo' essere considerato blasfemo?
Non lo so...
Ma a me fa ridere come uno str*nzo
Io... ho un sogno
Visto che siamo riusciti a catturare dinosauri...
... Fantasmi...
... E santi,
Mi piacerebbe andare oltre. Vorrei essere capace di programmare
Per creare l'app dei miei sogni:
"Non Più Vip Go"
Vorrei poter andare in giro a catturare Vip che la televisione non si caga più da anni
Ma che ci hanno accompagnato tra gli anni 80 fino ai primi del 2000
Sogno di trovare Ana Laura Ribas
E collezionarla lanciandole addosso un assegno a sei zeri
Immaginate di poter trovare dei Beppe Braida,
Unirli e farli evolvere in un Pippo Franco!
Non vedrei l'ora di camminare in città alla. Ricerca delle sorelle Lecciso SHINY
Senza dimenticarci dei Non Più Vip LEGGENDARI!
Magari farli apparire solo in eventi specifici, dove tutte le persone possano riunirsi sotto la stessa passione comune
Catturare Marco Columbro
Ma per lui servirebbe l'equivalente della master ball
...
un contratto mediaset
Ah, che sogno! E' questo di cui parlava Martin Luther King secondo me
*ride da solo*
:'D
A posto...